and this is the 90s Oh have you heard
about the new block on Nickelodeon
called 90s or all that every weekend
everything nothing ever went away it's
all still the 90s right
hey grant we are making some jokes with
the fashion stuff it's like it's not
it's just like during this block
sometimes like Keenan hosts it but they
run like all the little bumpers in
between shows and play yeah and all that
like they'll play episodes of all that
regrets are real monsters yeah well
since we're kind of supposed to be like
teenagers why not get a book or chicken
noodle soup for the tonight it was a big
nice thing 98 97 yeah
nice krispies well you get the fresh
snacks Cracker Jack I never liked
Cracker Jack yeah you kinda made that
joke we go this one place called soup oh
yeah there's one time he you know he's
like you know guy got some crackers with
the soup and she just put like eight
bags or something like that he's just
like it was fun I'm gonna get some of
these Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle snacks
I transcended the decades fuck that and
I love mr. turtle who the fuck that was
the idea that would be like the next
Batman or Superman right go past the
decade last forever
it's so timeless classic always unless
Jim could you hold this line for me
you're missing is that the Disney
Afternoon had a timeless magic okay
here's something you never see Malcolm
in weird makeup yeah you're just
standing there like you're waiting to
ask your daddy something dad can you uh
can you sir so beat up this black man
are you talking about Annie yeah she
looked pretty bad that was the one thing
I'm like oh that's mmm oh you haven't
heard about this new Annie okay you know
the original yeah do you like it
okay that's that's good that's a great
place to start
I hate it too so you won't be as angry
about this know that there's an anyway
it's Jamie Foxx it's um oh this is a
piece of southern wild' wherever that
girl is right it isn't that the girl
playing Annie and whoever the caretaker
is like the evil caretaker is played by
Cameron Diaz what well no it's like okay
like I seen her act like she can act
okay but it's like she's bad in this she
looks bad she she's out of her element
it feels you know but I don't make
she'll be good like a lot of people so I
Heath Ledger as the Joker it's like oh
that's gonna suck it he was great so I
thought I saw evening commissioner I'm
like oh this is gonna blow and then it's
like oh shit he may be so okay so like
you're female what are all these things
like that you're holy oh well the phone
obviously
is my phone that's my phone you wire
these are scrunchies do girls like still
wear scrunchies or not really cuz I did
I did buy them at a strive I bought it
no cuz buying a looker I asked my wife I
wear D games she's like Claire's
and I'm like you mean like this sort of
like the tween girls storage he's like
yeah so I don't know that met they were
still around or that I was clear these
are Claire's yes this was like a big
Claire's commercial I love it isn't it
for like if I'm right it's a cab for
like tweenage or like girls and stuff
yeah this really is a Claire's
commercial okay to be fair I think most
women's shit cause like a bajillion box
right like it isn't most of like isn't
half of what you're wearing like a
bajillion dollars yeah yes awesome but
guys don't meet as many accessories
that's it was just like shirt dawn
yeah now what's this lovely thing on
your head this is my the zebra gum form
into a hat
know what I like is that you know
everything here I got a Spencer's by the
way now it's gonna be a Spencer's
commercial like pretty much everything
came from Spencer's but I'm including
this hat because it's like Spencer says
everything 90s but here's the thing like
you look that you know it is it's a bomb
or at least half but in case you do know
right there it's like oh come on you
really need to like fine you're killing
me smalls
without that you're small that just says
you're killing and then show us the
killing oh my god I'm killing the fact
she has fraud Sam what I don't do that
say hey it was awesome
it's the great Hamby no no actually
that's something that we were saying we
did no it's cuz I got a no fear shirt
show that that's right I mean this is
like an actual retro no fear Church from
like the 90s and Jim and I were saying
they feel different and Jim was saying
the cloth actually is heavier yeah like
it actually does feel a little different
and you can see it seems to be okay and
when i zoom down to Bob Marley it was a
little odd all right when I went like
that went blurry yes I just got to a
point where wasn't today this seems to
be okay and these shirts too like all
these shorts except for my all these
shirts are worn backwards so like yeah
well was your say again magical
mothafucka guess Spencer's now and that
sure is worn backwards too because I
forgot like yeah everybody wore their
shirts like the labels were all in the
back for whatever reason
earlier today and then you turn around I
saw your shirt it's like oh my god they
were now I really thought you would know
that because when I went to California I
went to place called Pacific Beach and
it's like oh that's where the 90s went
it went to the beaches in California
because they had like these axure that's
where all the logos were on the they're
on the back of it yeah it's kind of like
Portland Oregon is where half the 90s
wind and the other half went to the
beaches of California yeah that's a good
way appointed let's say in Portlandia
90s is where young people go to retire I
check here see as I go right to the
other side well like that goes our
contacts or whatever yeah I mean I tried
I couldn't do it yeah actually hate
wearing glasses that's why I call myself
I got the classes the way I'm just gonna
hold it so now where am I supposed to
collapse I'm thinking was it okay but
I think what we'll have we'll have you
will have to it doesn't sound that close
these are gonna be like yeah that's why
we gotta have it on the well go ahead
because the Tamra has to be in the shot
to see its go ahead get up for a bit
let's assume yeah she's gonna be trying
to bring it back to life
and then maybe we won't eat these snacks
and I think about a lot of them have
been under your butt now Cheerios to
gets its spot again yeah like since I
started really I mean it's like the
first sketch I ever did it's why I keep
bringing in the back seven years
yeah actually maybe got a nice coating
of dust yes this intrigued me um so this
one looks like a backpack out of the 90s
but they didn't usually have speakers
and that confused me and I guess if you
open it up I'm not sure I think this is
for like I don't know like your iPod or
Sun because you can actually put
something in here and play from play
from here but I don't know what mp3
player something like that but I mean
it's just like how would you like to be
the douche going through like a train
station going to score whatever and have
a fucking music going through an asshole
yeah I have heard those before we're you
know people have like music coming out
of their backpack cool but that looks
really complicated well it's like what's
the it's like those guys always ride the
bikes and they have like the giant boom
box on it crank it up at their driver
[Applause]
like they don't look like especially big
speakers right it looked like there was
a battery pack in that like most
features you just plug your mp3 into it
yeah I've seen those hoodies with like
the earbuds on the drawstrings yeah the
more you know Pontius Pilate speaker I
got okay weird
no laughing it'll be no fun on the set
[Laughter]
so we don't know if they're 100%
it was the pink scrunchie that's always
like whatever we're like okay we're just
trying to be close it does have to be
perfect we always do you have a date
like let's roll family do you that guy
with the glasses disappointing they will
never love you again because they're hip
is this do quemic nikpay yeah yeah which
I finally got so annoyed with him I
stopped to use the room into a black
hole ya know we were thinking about
bringing like another life the syrup
says troll fan but he's like the really
depressed one cuz robberies mostly
common life there's always like one or
two that's just like dude it's like it's
okay you're not a fan but just kill your
son
I think there's more to life alright
time to knock you out
[Music]
[Laughter]
I've seen maybe two or three I'll be
serious though yeah well I like the
serious ones I'm like pieces to get
those of the four color girl one yeah
and I kept changing and they would
impose and stuff like that tomatoes like
a percent or something like that like
really like and then there's like
daddy's little girls
Ali I like that one okay because I'm
assuming this is for the
behind-the-scenes video of the episode
yeah oh oh here's the thing you got
here's the funny thing I love sharing
this back of people the fat grandma wig
is not a wig it's a beard whoa and in
fact if you looked at my last Christmas
videos you could see me wearing Atwater
two points
[Music]
[Laughter]
if mrs. Doubtfire wanted to do an
impression of woody the best approach to
it
oh yeah oh right to witness your
debauchery no no it's not offensive
because it's that like you know it's
like blackface or anything you know just
a funny character
[Laughter]
we both need the audio okay even the
dark green there proudly will not be a
Broncos the one in the bag is so bright
at so well lived by anything that's like
a legit I'll try to make no you
[Laughter]
[Music]
when other people imitate me and don't
have it busy right there do at least one
Batman penguins over years and years
we're doing this voice I'm eating
chicken fingers the only brother I can't
blame because I
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
when you do the voiceover changer it is
like a full paragraph and it's gonna be
free takes that's fine I got no it
doesn't
is exceedingly picometer you get
attached yeah it just looks very overly
technical though it's kind of funny